depuis ce lundi matin à près de 70
collaborateurs de l'entreprise n as low
as sur le traçage des personnes
atteintes du coc vie 19 dans la région
bruxelloise et en flandre prévenus par
les mutuelles les opérateurs réalisent
un véritable travail d'enquêteur
première étape appelé les personnes
diagnostiquées positivo coville 19 puis
identifier les personnes avec lesquelles
le malade a été en contact pendant les
48 heures précédant le début des
symptômes pour les salariés du call
center pas question d'espionner mais
bien le prévenir
on leur explique la raison notre appel
et surtout ce qui est intéressant aussi
c'est dire s'ils arrivent à nous
communiquer les contacts des personnes
avec qui ils étaient ensemble leur
anonymat est assuré et n'est pas
question d'une dénonciation ou de 2
voilà donc qui ne seront jamais qu'il
est la personne qui a donné leurs
coordonnées et voilà il ya quand même un
aspect qui d'abord rassurant et dire aux
gens voilà ce qu'ils font là souci un
geste pour les autres aussi pour les
personnes avec qui l'on est à
éventuellement contact tout à fait le
but de l'opération accentuer la
vigilance des personnes qui ont été en
contact avec les malades
une mission donc de sensibilisation qui
a aussi ses limites
les opérateurs ne peuvent pas obliger
les personnes concernées à communiquer
les coordonnées de ce qu'ils ont pu
croiser voilà il ya le geste à revoir
notamment voilà se met en quarantaine
éviter de et essayer voilà si la
personne debout ne répond pour voir qui
elle a pu rencontrer dans les jours
précédents au pouvoir faire le suivi et
arrêté ses transmissions
le siècle pas effectivement on ne peut
pas la contradiction pour chaque appel
le collaborateur devra suivre un script
bien précis qui le guide donc des
questions à poser en fonction des
réponses apportées par l'interlocuteur
à noter que l'anonymat des patients est
quant à lui garantit